rusia dice que las imágenes de muertos
en lucha son falsas y un montaje de
ucrania que sabe lo que ha visto ustedes
bien gracias buenas tardes en general
esas evidencias de los crímenes contra
la humanidad que hagas son reconocidas
por el corte internacional de justicia
entonces en el índice internacional no
es sólo la posición de ucrania es la
posición de las naciones unidas entonces
rusia por cierto yo estoy más que seguro
que los rusos van a responder en el
tribunal internacional de justicia y
esos eso sólo es cuestión de tiempo
cuando el presidente putin personalmente
va a ser condenado y detenido por el
corte interés internacional de justicia
por los horrores estos que estamos
viviendo en nuestras pantallas en los
alrededores de la capital
en su opinión lo que está sucediendo en
ucrania es un genocidio de rusia como
denuncia volodymyr selenski hay pruebas
que permitan en el futuro de este
escenario que usted describe de un
juicio por crímenes de guerra de horacio
como en este político y yo entiendo que
es un genocidio pero no sólo aquí en la
región de la capital en solo en un
ciudad de mariupol ya murieron más que
5.000 personas civiles eso para
compartir es cuando fue un genocidio en
bosnia enemigos la vida dura en los años
noventas allí murieron cerca de 8000
personas aquí ya tenemos 5.000 personas
sólo en una ciudad de marjah huerta aquí
cerca de la capital tenemos casi un mil
personas puede apreciar entonces eso por
cierto va a ser un llamado como un
genocidio contra los ucranianos porque
pagan por que fusilaron para la gente
civil porque puedan ucranianos no no
bien eso no fue una batalla durante una
batalla contra el ejército ucraniano por
que fusilaron exterminaron la gente de
civil como rehenes eso tiene sólo una
como un genocidio nada más
mire y en medio de todas las
preocupaciones de la guerra le quiero
preguntar cómo es el proceso para dar
sepultura a los fallecidos especialmente
sabiendo que probablemente sus
familiares huyeron y no hay quienes
reciba a estos restos mortales bien
mucha gente está desconocido para mucha
gente ahora mismo está desconocido
porque
esto a veces es muy difícil hacer ver de
qué sexo es la persona entonces por eso
ahora aquí esperamos para que en el
nivel internacional las organizaciones
humanitarias también en la cruz roja lo
van a trabajar aquí con todos esos
hechos de todos esos crímenes para
organizar el proceso como 17 y yo estoy
seguro que muchas muchas familias no van
a recibir las respuestas a dónde están
sus familiares yo también conozco la
gente desconocido algunos mis colegas
viven en el pin de la ciudad cerca de
buche ahora mismo yo no sé dónde estás
dónde está esa gente por eso es de veras
ts aborto coca la familia en todo el
país es un todo no sólo alguna cosa
local